♪♪
-Hey, everybody.
Welcome to "Corrections."
We all-in?
[ Laughter ]
I, um...
I told you I received a Lego guy
with an Emmy,
but he couldn't hold the Emmy,
which I thought
was part of the joke.
A bunch of the Lego enthusiasts
who watch this show
told me exactly
how he could hold it.
So that's how it looks.
Thank you, psychos.
[ Laughter ]
Um, last week
on "A Closer Look,"
we talked about goldfish
at Mar-a-Lago.
We said Mar-a-Lago
looked like a...
castle you put
in a goldfish bowl.
That was the photo we used.
A bunch of you said
those aren't goldfish.
In our defense, they are
very hard fish to find.
[ Laughter ]
The rarest.
It would be like
if someone said,
"I'll take a turkey sandwich."
This short notice?
W-Where in the city?!
The parts at IKEA
don't have weird names --
just the finished product.
They use numbers or letters
so that they can work
internationally --
numbers like "Klurgentop."
[ Laughter ]
Letters like "Shyorlnd."
We made a joke about
somebody getting caught twice
on "To Catch a Predator."
Same dude.
Turns out that happened.
[ Laughter ]
And I guess...
the dude wanted it to happen.
You always hear pedophiles
have a very hard time in prison.
They're treated very badly.
Justifiably so.
But I guess if you are a
pedophile who gets caught twice,
it's like a double negative.
King of the cellblock.
I'm not gonna criticize
prison rules.
I referred to a sobriety test
as a drunk-driving test.
Obviously, it's called
a sobriety test.
There are still parts
of the South
where they give you
a drunk-driving test,
and if you do well enough,
they just send you off.
[ Laughter ]
"Just stay on the shoulder,
Cletus!"
[ Laughter ]
Fat Bear Week is held
in an Alaskan national park.
I pronounced that park
"cat, my."
It's pronounced "cat, may."
The bears request
you pronounce fat "big-boned."
[ Man laughs ]
Oh, thank you, Bucky.
[ Laughter ]
"I went down
to the Five and Dime, Bucky,
and I told 'em
my fat-bear joke,
and not a smile!
But I knew
you'd like it, Bucky.
I told 'em, and I'm like,
'You aren't
cracking a smile, now.'"
[ Laughter ]
"My Bucky.
When my Bucky hears my jokes,
he slaps his knee so hard,
we're gonna have to
have it replaced!"
[ Laughter ]
We talked about Donald Trump
referring to a gorilla
in the Bronx Zoo as Mongo.
There is not a gorilla
in the Bronx Zoo named Mongo.
There is one named Ernie,
and someone said,
"Do yourself a favor
and look at the picture of Ernie
they have on the website."
And I thought, what could
possibly be worth it?
And the answer is...this.
[ Laughter ]
This is what Ernie
would look like
if he also was arrested
on January 6th.
Monday's "Closer Look,"
we had a joke about Scrabble
and we showed a bunch
of Scrabble pieces.
This is what we showed.
Okay? That was in the key.
The key is the little square
over my shoulder, right?
Someone wrote,
"Not only is the Q missing
from the Scrabble game,
but you have an extra X,
where Scrabble games
only have one X tile.
Also, there are four S tiles,
not six as shown."
My question to you is,
how big is your [bleep] TV?
[ Laughter ]
This was a very good graphic
that I should have
given more credit
to the graphics department for
about someone smoking weed
out of a CVS receipt.
And I was told receipts
come from thermal printers,
which use BPA in the paper.
That is a chemical.
BPA is a chemical called
bisphenol,
which is an endocrine disruptor.
They should not be smoked
because they contain
carbon and graphite.
They're very dangerous.
But isn't danger
a little bit of the fun?
[ Laughter ]
Scollins wrote a joke
about dead bodies
in McDonald ball pits.
I was told there haven't been
PlayPlaces in McDonald's
since at least 2010.
They shut them down
because they were crime scenes.
I said there were not ushers
at football games.
I was told by a lot of people
there are ushers
at football games.
In my defense, they just take me
right to the luxury box.
[ Laughter ]
I know not of A-25, B-44.
But once I sit,
I'm just like you --
watching our competing squads
duke it out on the gridiron.
I enjoy a hot-dog sandwich
as much as the next
work-a-day Joe.
A nice tall glass of --
Shoemaker, what's that
pauper's ale you enjoy?
Boodveiser.
[ Laughter ]
I was told -- We always --
In the preface to
Surprise Inspection,
we described the jokes
as unusable,
and I was told by a lot
of people they are usable
once you put them
in Surprise Inspection
because they're on TV.
Fine.
[ Laughter ]
Um, we said Nancy Mace
looked like
she was wearing
an "A" on her chest,
that she looks like
she hangs out
by Oscar's trash can
selling drugs.
And then we had her saying,
"Psst. Elmo."
People thought it was a mistake.
If she was hanging out
by Oscar's trash can,
why wouldn't she say it
to Oscar?
But you wouldn't sell
Oscar drugs
because he doesn't have
the money for it.
[ Laughter ]
I'm very disappointed still --
I feel like today's generation
doesn't know
that Stevie Nicks
was the scarf lady.
I mean, it's kind of a bummer.
I feel like Johnny Depp,
like, became the scarf guy,
but she's a far better,
nontoxic scarf person.
She's, like,
the best at scarves.
You hear she's opening
a new scarf place?
You know what it's called?
Scarf Face.
[ Laughter ]
It's called Scarf Face.
And I saw the commercial.
She's like,
"We got big scarves...
medium scarves.
Say hello to my little friend."
[Bleep]
[ Laughter ]
Clutched on the scarf!
We were also talking about
"Silver Springs"
is the greatest revenge song
of all time.
Stevie Nicks writes
"Silver Springs"
about Lindsey Buckingham,
and it's the best.
And it's a bummer --
It was supposed
to be on "Rumours."
She had the publishing to it.
She gave the publishing
to her mom.
"Rumours" is one of the
best-selling albums of all time.
Lindsey Buckingham
wouldn't let it be on "Rumours."
She was mad about it forever.
And then in the late '90s,
they did a live concert.
It's one of the great
live concert performances
because she's singing this song,
this breakup song about
Lindsey Buckingham, to him
while he has to
play along with it.
And I was so bummed because
I would love to show it to you
as a bit of music education,
but as I established last week,
we've got this music licensing
issue, right?
If we show it, it can't stay up.
But then one of
you legal eagles...
said, "You can play a song
with the exception
that if you're reviewing
or reacting to it,
it's considered
critiquing a work,
which is covered under fair use,
and thus means YouTube
would not take it down.
So as long as you play
the music clip
and then give an opinion on it,
you should be covered."
So this is a clip
of Stevie Nicks
and Lindsey Buckingham.
If you want to know
which one is which,
Stevie Nicks is the one
with the scarves.
Take a look.
♪ I'll follow you down ♪
♪ Till the sound of my voice ♪
♪ Will haunt you ♪
♪♪
♪ Give me just a chance ♪
♪ You will never get away,
never get away ♪
♪ From the sound of the woman
that loves you ♪
-♪ Never get away ♪
♪♪
And my opinion is,
that's [bleep] rad.
So we good.
[ Laughter ]
I said that "Edge of Seventeen"
is a Baba O'Riley situation,
which is
you should be calling it
the thing we all think it is.
In its defense, at least,
"Edge of Seventeen"
is in white-winged Doug --
White-winged Doug?
[ Laughter ]
But there's no -- "Baba O'Riley"
does not appear --
The words "Baba O'Riley" do not
appear in "Teenage Wasteland."
Another -- You gave me some
good other examples of that.
"Good Riddance"
is the Green Day song
that should be called
"Time of Your Life."
"For What It's Worth"
is a Buffalo Springfield song
that never mentions
"For what it's worth."
The Who did this a lot.
Obviously, "Baba O'Riley" should
be called "Teenage Wasteland."
The song that you think
should be called
"Won't Get Fooled Again"
is called "Jeff McIntyre."
[ Laughter ]
Alright.
Scollins did this.
We all remember Scollins
wore a tank top, right?
Then, uh,
got some art sent to us
by a wonderful artist
named T.J.
He sent that. It was great.
Then, the other day, I'm in
the audience doing the Q&A,
and I notice a guy wearing
the Scollins tank-top art.
I ask, and it is the dude
who drew it. Came to our show.
And so Scollins
posted this photo,
and all the comments
were like,
"Whoa, that dude's
so [bleep] hot."
And Scollins and I want to know
when you say "that dude,"
do you mean me
or the Scollins in the drawing?
[ Laughter ]
We're of two minds.
♪ Doo-doo-doo-doo ♪
Someone wrote a comment
that I really enjoyed this week.
"When I watch 'Corrections,'
I don't know what's happening."
[ Laughter ]
That's the goal.
That's how this is different.
We're not the normal pablum
you're fed.
We're challenging you.
Speaking of challenging,
last week,
I tried to do three
noncontiguous fingers
to show how Ron DeSantis
eats pudding,
and it did take me longer
than I thought it would take.
And someone said, "Why does it
take him that long to do it?"
Interestingly enough,
doing three
noncontiguous fingers
is considered
a drunk-driving test.
[ Laughter ]
Heh.
Um, someone said it is --
This is a Jackal
Joke of the Week.
Someone said, "Negroni
is a good drink for this
because when I hear your jokes,
I'm at home ne-groaning."
So congrats on the win.
[ Laughter ]
I got some bad news, though.
Want to see the trophy?
Um, the gentleman who made these
reached out.
He was angry because --
He wanted to make it clear.
These are called head jackals.
He also was upset
because he attached a video
of how they're made.
Uh, and he wanted me
to show them to people.
I don't know if you want
to see how they're made.
What happens is, like,
a mommy one of these
and a daddy one of these...
[ Laughter ]
I said it's "patented."
Someone said, "When it's art,
it's a copyright, not patent."
"Art."
[ Laughter ]
I do -- Let's see what else. Oh!
You know, I think
a lot of people thought...
Oh, people have been
criticizing my nails
and saying I need a manicure.
I'm gonna try not --
I'm not gonna show them to you.
I'm gonna try to get my nails
in good shape,
because then I am
gonna show you --
I'm gonna make
these jackals hump,
but I'm gonna wait
until my fingers
are pretty enough for it.
A lot of people thought
I was faking
Scollins and Wally coming in.
Uh, well, guess what.
We got some Zapruder footage
for ya. Roll it, Alex.
I want to start by saying,
if you can sense a vibe --
Are you [bleep] kidding me?
[ Laughter ]
Wally and Scollins come in
chatting it up.
[ Laughter ]
During "Corrections."
Is nothing sacred in this place?
[ Smooching ]
"Should we? Oh, I don't know."
"What if...
What if someone sees us?"
"No one's watching."
[ Smooching ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Ominous violin screeching ]
Would you guys believe
we don't rehearse?
[ Laughter ]
First time we ever did that.
Stevie Nicks week.
[see ya next week]